[Music]
[Laughter]
this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash already into
episode 125 I'm live on my app here 123
sorry I meant this II don't know why I
said 125 to you until they were brutally
honest with you guys I actually stopped
thinking of the number in the middle of
the number that's how [ __ ] ADHD I am
I was literally like 120 and then
thought and then just said five for no
reason
so that's where I'm at today Monday some
date and in 2019 but I'm literally 95%
sure it's 2019 because I haven't thought
about what year or month or date it is
since I got out of [ __ ] high school
it might it could be a new day it could
be [ __ ] Friday Saturday Sunday it
could be you know some new day they made
a porter day I have no idea that they've
made it even [ __ ] bond day like those
[ __ ] Instagram homies do so yeah it
could be a new day that they made up for
all I [ __ ] know for all intensive
purposes for all intents and purposes
people [ __ ] that up all the time but
it's episode 123 I'm live on my app you
can go into the App Store and get it
Chris D'Elia just type that [ __ ]
in and and you and you figure it out and
you figure it out and you figure it out
and you just download it you know people
always are like how do I do it what do I
do
just do it just do it just [ __ ] do it
pretty much I have that 50 please and 50
no more shirt or whatever I put it on my
Instagram and people are like ah dude
you need to release this how do I get
this
how do I get this type it in type it
into the [ __ ] browser and you'll find
out that 50 cent sells this shirt okay
and why does he sell the shirt well
because but I have shows coming up in
Hoover Alabama Memphis Tennessee
Chattanooga Tennessee
and Knoxville and it and it si and
Knoxville and it C dude we're doing a
thing where I'm stop I'm forgetting I'm
just bowing out in the middle of words
the more so I woke up today real groggy
not gonna lie to my babies all right I
woke up real groggy bags under my eyes
luckily they're Prada okay but I've got
bags under my eyes and I'm not lying you
can get a surgery to get the bags
removed under your eyes and I've always
been against surgery but I should do it
because it would take years off of my
look now I'm a [ __ ] spring chicken
dude I'm 13 ah dude I'm not even 40 okay
and I mean I'm busting out of my shirt I
mean yeah my left my legs look like
[ __ ] my shoes look like olives on
toothpicks but still dude mmm
busting you understand traps doubts
[ __ ] you name it chest abs I swear to
God one time I looked really closer to
my house was a little guy skiing down I
didn't know they made people that little
but they did Jesus made a [ __ ] guy
that little and he was skiing down my
ABS and I just let him go right down to
my dick um and then just did one of
those [ __ ] long jumps off the dick
you know how they do
he went down some moguls off of my
[ __ ] ABS my little [ __ ] Hawaiian
dinner rolls and then [ __ ] boom it
went down sloped off the shaft of my
dick and when ye so that's the kind of
[ __ ] life I'm leading and then but
that's it now one fire just played
something off his computer
it went loud off the speaker's one
fire and that is why he's one fire and
that's fine well if I yes that bags are
in my eyes yes
would I have to check throughout the
airport yes could I put them on over her
but no would they make me tag them while
I [ __ ] him before I put them into their
place yes it's okay yes
doesn't matter to Carly doesn't matter
okay but it's all good how about the
[ __ ] long jump in skiing though for
real like what are you doing that's some
[ __ ] that should have just stopped in
the 50s when they were like this is
exciting did you say you jump so long
and it's so far some of these [ __ ]
Olympics events it's like what hey what
the luge hey dude
any event that you can literally clip
your nails while you're doing it take it
out of the Olympics also shot put just
throwing a ball hey make it more
interest make it more intricate hey dude
Oh shot put oh but you know what there's
a basketball hey [ __ ] what's the one
the javelin oh really there's football
guy just running so [ __ ] too because
he's always hopping you know oh it's so
funny how they hop so [ __ ] they throw
that [ __ ] though that's [ __ ] who
cares you know I love how people are
like oh I love the Olympics one Olympics
coming out nobody hears that you know
people don't give a [ __ ] about the
Olympics for real nobody talks about the
Olympics when the Olympics aren't
happening that's how you know and people
are like nah just loved I love it I'd
love to watch one fire [ __ ] pretends
to love it dude he [ __ ] and and and
when there's you never hear about it
when people aren't swimming or throwing
[ __ ] ice picks you never think about
it nobody ever talks about it unless
somebody's got their [ __ ] shot put
like this like they're trying to get
serviced in the jungle and [ __ ]
twisting around and then throwing it
people get people talk about basketball
all year long he'll talk about baseball
all year long people talk about football
all year long you know what people don't
talk about all year long the [ __ ]
pommel horse uh or whatever the hell
it's called guys just swing it around
swinging around you know that when they
do the pommel horse you know they're
going also what are you wearing PJs hey
dude why are you in footies you [ __ ]
28 year old shoulders for days though
dude
talk about a shoulder workout if you do
the pommel horse if you're the [ __ ]
rings you can literally you could
literally rip apart people's [ __ ]
face
you go in their mouth and just rip it
open and the glove doesn't know how and
you go traps that's did you say look at
these videos there's one video YouTube
tops my top seven favorite gymnastic
rings [ __ ] videos hey men wow that's
a fan hey all dude nobody [ __ ] Asians
dude rings you know why Asians because
their legs are [ __ ] four four pounds
look at the way they do it do it they
just to be able to just hold the Rings
like that dude I mean how do they do
this [ __ ] unbeliev I gotta get good at
that if you could do the Rings god
that's so funny that you could be so fit
and be so awesome at the Rings but
probably still get no chicks you know
cuz you're like he does what girl wants
to be like oh yeah what's your boyfriend
do oh you want he does the Rings what
he's a jeweler no you know it's [ __ ]
to handlebar rings that [ __ ] come
down from the heavens also why are they
always so tethered so high like you
could literally have a [ __ ] ribbon
that big it could be a foot I guess they
gotta go high so there could be six feet
but they're always coming from the
heavens dude they're always coming from
500 feet up Jesus is up there holding
the [ __ ] ribbons like this mole the
Asian will do what we'll do that's what
Jesus is thinking so Croatian to be good
at went with the rings dude it's so
Croatian to be good at the rings dude
you know what it's so Croatian to be
[ __ ] living so hard to do the
Olympics dude to be [ __ ] they talked
about you know who talks about the
Olympics all your [ __ ] long Croatian
stupid everyday Croatians in Croatia say
well the Olympics are coming up you know
so oh [ __ ] dude Wow
that makes me laugh dude thinking about
Croatians loving the [ __ ] Olympics I
I did the [ __ ] uh I did a personal
trainer I I worked I worked in a with a
personal trainer the other day till to
because I wanted to make sure I was
doing everything right with my squats
because I got [ __ ] because they do
they literally start calling me Johnny
hips cry at the [ __ ] gym because of
my [ __ ] the tear drops below above my
kneecaps and so it something goes huh
Johnny hips cry I'm like what do it come
on man and you're like well your [ __ ]
legs are what the [ __ ] I thought maybe a
horse was galloping by and I go no no no
it's me so I just making sure that when
I [ __ ] load the bar up on my back
that I was dipping correctly turns out
dip incorrectly do you know why because
I have good posture I have really good
posture and I know that sometimes my
posture is too much the other way
sometimes my posture is so good my the
back of my head is per is [ __ ]
perpendicular with the ground and I'm
looking up to the heavens
I'm trying to look where they're [ __ ]
where the Rings are attached but yeah
cuz and then people are like why is your
posture so good it looks like you're
you're facing the sky and I always say
because I always want to see what Jesus
is up to because I'm very religious and
so and so but I have really good posture
and the reason why I have really good
posture is because
my my dad would always my dad would
always be like hey stand up straight
he'd always be like hey and hit me on
the back of the head really lightly not
child abuse and be like stand up
straight and I'd be like what okay
so now I [ __ ] look like I walk around
like I'm in a Marvel movie do it because
you have to dude that's who you are and
it's a vulnerable position to people are
like oh you're trying to [ __ ] be
alpha no I'm not I'd go like this here's
my chest man stab me if you need I'm
vulnerable baby this is life stabbed me
in the front it's a vulnerable position
dude walking around like this you walk
around like this not vulnerable you walk
around like this that's when you're in
sick that's when you're insecure dude
you're meek walk around with your
[ __ ] chest out let people stab if
they want and then look at them in their
eyes and say I hope you enjoyed this its
life baby anyway I did it and I know I
have a good form apparently the guy said
so that makes me feel good no I still
have back problems
yes is it from getting all day yes am I
not even 40 yet yes but Dora Berkley yes
is because I'm a fracture because I felt
when I was a girl yes did I have to go
to the doctor seven times to figure out
what it was until the actual doctor that
was really good at it came in and tell
me what it was cuz he looked at the
x-ray and this is what he's obsessed
about in his life
yes then it cost me money a little bit
because I've insurance yes is America
[ __ ] up when it comes to insurance and
one comes to medical so yes it's okay
though because I'm in a fortunate
position because I'm a money yes it's
not bad for a buddy yes I can do
anything about it no am I too lazy to
even look it up in google it and [ __ ]
figure out something to do yes
so anyway um so anyway dude I I [ __ ]
did it and I basically did all the the I
basically did all the the workouts that
I kind of do already but for some reason
when you do with a personal trainer
you're gonna be [ __ ] so much more sore
than
next day I mean he was like so you know
he's a buddy of mine comes to my show
sometimes he was like so uh yeah his
name's Rocco and he was like so by the
way of course name's Rocco [ __ ]
personal trainer named Rocco so he's
like so you got to go days like he
basically told me you know when you're
when you're when you're when you're
lifting weights you think of the
powerful move as you know if you're
doing chest pushing out or if you're
squatting pushing up but he does this
whole thing or if you go in if you go
controlled down and then explode up and
you control yourself going down for like
four seconds and then explode up that
you'll be you get more of a foundation
and all your [ __ ] muscles that you
don't normally use will get really
stronger really a lot stronger a really
stronger secretion and so I did that and
in the next day I was walking around
like somebody [ __ ] my ass anyway I was
real sore but is it all good my babies
yeah is it good now yes that I used the
Thera gun to try and make it work and
and and and even out my soreness yes so
anyway I did that and I was real sore
and it's all good and it's fine do it
but I'm not an Olympian I realized that
I'm 39 dude and like the last I'm just
like I always think about when my dad I
would say dad you get nervous around
cops and they said no not really anymore
and I said what do you mean not anymore
and he said because I'm older than most
of them and I was like wow that's
interesting I was thought about that
when I was a little kid I was like I'm
younger than most cops pretty soon I'm
gonna be older than most cops now I
don't think I'm probably older than most
cops now maybe I am but I think that
about I think about that I related to
like [ __ ] activity [ __ ] like I'm
never gonna be stronger than I was I
mean maybe I maybe I will be stronger
but I'm never gonna be able to be
capable to be strong of being stronger
than I was when I was like 27 Wow what's
it matter we have computers right
it doesn't matter we have computers it's
not we don't live a glad it's a
gladiator life anymore we live with
[ __ ] beauties we live beauty's babies
so I'm never gonna be an Olympian and
that's fine
because never wanted to be because you
know I wouldn't never be dude if I was
an Olympian holy [ __ ] [ __ ] I'd get
fired immediately they'd be like you got
to go back to Croatia bro you're [ __ ]
it up you're making people laugh when
they're on the high beams and they break
their [ __ ] ankles you don't want to
wear the outfit and I'm like their
footage dude
sports are insane dude sports make
people insane do you see the thing about
that on Twitter with a girl the soccer
girl was like we should get paid equal
as [ __ ] men's soccer players yeah I
mean I'm all for that you gotta get more
people will sit in the seats I'm all for
that
however you get people to care you know
it isn't it isn't that how it is isn't
it a [ __ ] supply and demand thing I
mean I can have the better okay I could
[ __ ] sell candy if nobody's buying it
nobody's buying it then I got lots of
candy you're in a position soccer girl
or you got lots of candy you got bags
full of candy and guess what only some
people want that candy and you're saying
hey this sucks
this other guy's got candy and he's
selling at all that's not fair
okay that's as far as that goes you know
how far it goes it goes this far okay
I said you're mad cuz you can't sell you
candy life's not fair if I may
bunch of chairs and nobody wanted the
chairs are you know only some people one
of the chairs now granted the people who
watch I don't know I don't know III
don't I know nothing about sports but
what I do know is you get the money
you're worth for the most of for the
most of I mean there's definitely some
situations where you know maybe women
get underpaid and [ __ ] like that but
soccer isn't one of them because you can
just if you're a star you get paid right
if you're as big as David Beckham didn't
[ __ ] they would pay you David Beckham
money also get the endorsements man
that's the [ __ ] real money isn't it
[ __ ] do an ad for Snickers dude doing
that for Snickers doing that for [ __ ]
living spaces when I'm not on the field
kicking balls I'm kicking it at home
living space is you ever buy some
furniture from living spaces bro that
should have last that that shit's by the
way that [ __ ] I IKEA does it last
no living spaces I feel like they make
it I feel like that they still got [ __ ]
in Chernobyl and it's all good
they have you been watching Chernobyl
there's one more episode left a
miniseries
and I'm hooked on it dude and it's
really good really good it's it's
there's it's sometimes it's a little
you're like wow it's a little much with
the realism it's like okay I'm not
watching a documentary right you don't
need to show a guy I'm literally looking
at a guy and he's only teeth and
eyeballs but it's so good and it's so
gray
they only be the only color in it is
gray and nobody's talking in Russian
accents which is super weird to me
here's the thing I love the show it's
great and now I'm gonna make fun of it
I heard the guy the Creator the right
are talking about it he was like well we
chose not to do a Russian accent because
a Russian accent can be really comical
if if you're not careful
and it's like no a Russian accent is
only comical if you make it comical dude
if you're they put Russian accent these
guys as faces we're falling off and [ __ ]
in them in the documentary any and
you're like oh oh no they're shooting
the animals because they're radioactive
and you're like oh no you think because
someone's like you have to shoot the
animal we're gonna be like No so they're
not talking here's the other thing too
if you're gonna abandon them talking in
Russian accent first of all having to
speak Russian and make it subtitles if
you were going for realism alright if
you're not doing that you have them
speak the Russian accents if you're not
doing that then just have them just be
their regular accent or American or
whatever the [ __ ] is an American show
right so but they're not some of the
guys are [ __ ] Irish some of the guys
are Swedish some of the guys are [ __ ]
literally British it it makes me it
takes me out of it for sure when they're
like when it's like in Russia and he's
like what we're gonna do everyone's
faces have fallen off comrade what he's
like I thought guys literally blood and
bones comrade like why oh the guys got a
[ __ ] third arm growing out of his
[ __ ] forehead comrade I just saw a
dog with no snout and an extra dick on
his ass comrade what we gonna do oh I
got a [ __ ] 9 what's Russian what's
Russian food I mean how bad is Russian
food that I don't even know one Russian
food for real what our traditional
Russians foods oh Jesus Oh borscht of
course
so this this how you know Russian food
sucks do it third one down
sweet-and-sour cabbage look at this
beef stroganoff those are the two I know
that's it borscht and beef stroganoff
look at what they go what goes from the
down from after that it will goes down
sweet and sour cabbage least I know what
it is then from then on it's just you
[ __ ] figure it out right here
so Janka soup I feel like that has like
literal screws in it and like bolts you
know like what the [ __ ] and they're just
like eat up it's good for you good you
eat it it's strong you eat the [ __ ]
bolts go in your body become part of you
eat now here's another one go go up see
go up see literally nothing else just
who knows could be [ __ ] goat dicks
have no idea it literally could be goat
dicks and dirt eat up galovski go up see
what is it go dick and dirt eat it with
the so lianca soup you'd be big and
strong you have God dick and bolts in
you Olivier Olivier olivia is another
one blini I think I've heard of that
potato okroshka okroshka potato okroshka
wow that's that's some real [ __ ]
sounding food beef stroganoff dude
my roommate used to make beef stroganoff
and I used to be like yo dude it looks
like someone took a [ __ ] on a place to
play the pasta beef stroganoff aka
dumped on pasta evacuation pasta let me
go through some of these [ __ ] things
after the first ad I'm gonna do the ad
right now because I feel like [ __ ]
backing it up dude quip it's time to
celebrate your new grad or check off
that annual gift for Dad
treat their teeth to an electric
toothbrush from quip and help them build
good habits for the future
the signature guiding features will not
only be a gentle reminders to stick to a
daily self-care routine but will keep
their smile bright wherever they go
sensitive sonic vibrations effective
clean and is very gentle on your
sensitive gums
I've sensitive gums I use clip and it's
great people brush too hard some
electric toothbrushes are too abrasive
not clip a multi-use cover is very cool
it this thing looks like it was created
in the future I love it and it's got a
mount that you can put it on your mirror
and it unmount Stu slide over your
bristles for on-the-go brushing it
declares your sink you know a lot of
people just have those two purses around
and it looks stupid and janky anyway I
love quip for keeping my teeth dentist
clean on the road and that's why I love
clip and why 1 million happy healthy
mouths do to quip starts at just 25
dollars if you go to get clipped calm /
Congrats right now you get your first
refill pack free with a clip electric
toothbrush that's your first refill pack
free at GE tqu IP comm / congrats a
farmers dog look dog food I love my dogs
do you love your dogs you have dogs you
must love them dog food companies love
using fancy recipe names and colorful
pictures for real meat and veggies on
their bag but it seems no matter what
the brand or price or the ingredients on
the label all you find inside are
unidentified dried-out brown nuggets now
I think we understand as babies so gross
why do we accept these things or this as
food let alone healthy food no for
living beings as awesome as dogs I don't
think so dogs are better than people so
we should you know put food in them that
is better than us right that would put
in us what kind of beef or carrots can
sit on a shelf for months or even years
gross
highly processed nap preservative heavy
NAT introducing the farmers dog the
company helping dogs live longer
healthier lives by making it easy and
convenient to feed their fresh food then
fresh food the recipes are made fresh
and delivered directly to your door all
you have to do is complete a short
questionnaire
personalized vet to vet develop
developed meet plan a meal plan create
creator for your dog I did it for my
dogs is really cool deliver to the dog
to the to my dogs and they ate it up
dude
they loved it and they're healthier for
it and they're gonna live days longer
because of it
it's proportion and all that it's pretty
cool start feeding your dog better today
get 50% off your two week trial huh
fresh healthy food at the farmer's dog
calm slash Congrats plus you get free
shipping just go to the farmers dog calm
/ congrats and get 50% off your two
weeks trial
that's the farmer dog the farmer's dog
calm / Congrats
love your dogs is that it Fred alright
cool do another one later I don't want
to [ __ ] do it now but I'll talk to
you about this [ __ ] borscht sweet and
sour cabbage that's the only thing that
by the way looks kind of good the
Russian food cabbage cooked in red wine
vinegar apple sauce butter and onions I
don't know about all that
diced apples sugar Bailey yeah it's
really sweet sounds like Solyanka soup
hearty soup made from thick chunks of
beef and pork cooked that looks bangin
actually garlic do you put garlic on
something it's over I'll eat it all ice
- I swear to God put Chloe put a [ __ ]
garlic all over your dick I'll eat it I
don't give a [ __ ] have clothes for your
balls I'm in I'm in dude look at this
goal up see this [ __ ] this looks
terrible shred it or minced beef wrapped
in cabbage what's up with cabbage dude
Russia they're just like we have it
pulled it in everything
that's gross yeah
Russians like to add some sour cream on
top ill lieu this [ __ ] ill Oh Livie Oh
Livie potatoes pickles baloney eggs I
mean just all of it and carrots swimming
in a bowl of mayo I don't like when
people use words that shouldn't be in
the description like swimming no they're
not [ __ ] doing laps dude potatoes
pickles baloney eggs and carrots
bubblegum rice krispie treats water and
[ __ ] Castrol GT swimming in a bowl of
Mayo what does it taste like is the most
quintessential of all Russian salads
every cook has his own recipe and it's
staple for every Russian blini thin
crepe like pancakes made from unleavened
dough yeah okay that looks fine oh wow
potato okay Oh crush god that looks
horrible Oh a cold soup hey by the way
soup hot [ __ ] dis gazpacho [ __ ] [ __ ] any
cold soup dude soup cold should be a
drink anything cold umm I'm putting in
my mouth and it's liquid so drink I'm
drinking it soup cold soup you're lazy
dude heat it up putting the [ __ ]
microwave it doesn't taste good like
that then don't make it
oh gosh chica a cold soup made from
buttermilk gross potatoes and onions
gross garnished with dill gross they
should call this potato breath be bad
there you call this potato coming out
the other end smelling better
hey hey potato okay hey wow this smells
like [ __ ] awful donkey balls how do
we make it smell better either than [ __ ]
it out okay Bravo
sweet ever Damon Wayans Jr funniest
sweet ever left so hard he said man oh
boy this is the best use of Twitter ever
I've tried to find this tweet again
later can't find it it doesn't exist
anymore dude
maybe he deleted it I [ __ ] text him
after this bro I laughed so hard I cried
that funny sweet I ever heard he wrote
he wrote hey first of all his bio is
hilarious real Mensch it standing up
dude he wrote this tweet he said man
when you're hungry everything smells
good and then he put in quotes hey MA
what do you cook oh wait no no no no he
wrote when you're hungry everything
smells oh here it is here it is Wow one
fire found it one higher okay you're
right you know what
you know you're hungry when everything
starts to smell good and then in quotes
he writes mmm is that doodoo and then I
wrote I'm dying why this is in 2015 I'm
[ __ ] dying you just wrote that holy
Sh I'm laughing so hard real for real
top 10 tweets ever he wrote lmao my name
is Damon and I'm 5 oh that guy makes me
laugh bro Damon Wayans Jr is so [ __ ]
funny dude he makes me laugh I want to
be in a [ __ ] show with that guy I
feel like we would have [ __ ] I feel
like we would be funny together is that
do do do it so overboard oh man that's
the best usage of Twitter alright here
we go here's here's another one
knish nish you just pronounced the K
knish what is it mashed potatoes ground
beef onions and cheese filled inside
thick dough pastry and deep fried B I
mean they just designed that to try and
be the best tasting possible thing ever
King Kali dumplings of ground beef and
cilantro dude I love cilantro bro
I'll eat it like a snack some people
think it tastes like soap I think I mean
how many [ __ ] there's like the top
how many top
17:18 chok chok didn't try with the name
deep fried balls or little logs of
unleavened dough I mean trying to make
it sound so bad
chalk chalk so these are deep fried
balls or little logs enjoy I love
comments dude look at this idiot
khinkali and catch poori are Georgian
food not [ __ ] Russian okay well
Russia was definitely around before was
it around before Georgia probably right
well how long how old is Russia uh
anyway enough of that why am I talking
about [ __ ] Russian food
look who's near line cuz nobody talked
about it
guy came up to me at Starbucks today and
he was like hey man for Sauza I said
Starbucks as I need to [ __ ] I needed
to taste what it tastes like on the
inside of a [ __ ] cat back of a cow's
mouth God Starbucks [ __ ] sucks but it
was this closest that's how they get you
dude there's a [ __ ] I went into a
Starbucks once and I was like what's
this store and I walked into it and
there was another Starbucks there like
hey what's up you need coffee and I was
like I just came in from the Starbucks
in are like yeah yeah we got Starbucks
in here too okay um I feel like
seriously though in Chernobyl there's
still a functioning Starbucks and people
with [ __ ] arms coming out of their
back walk in well ability who you here
for yeah there's one guy that comes in I
don't know if he's six or 75 but he
comes in here and gets coffee
and then we also have a few stray dogs
and ladybugs that we serve - yeah oh and
OH does it still tense at the back of a
Cosmo yeah says guy came up to me and he
had a hat that said for real
cheeseburger on it okay
take it off make a fire put the hat in
the fire walk around like that without
that hat I'm just doing you a favor and
he said hey man Chris D'Elia and I said
D'Elia yeah what's up and he said oh
sorry man I said not OK he said amen
I really want to really want to be
really really enjoy your really thumb
fan um I saw odd do you need a like a
runner or an intern or anything like
that and I was like I'm a comedian I
don't really do [ __ ] except stand-up yes
I go okay cool well I said you're trying
to get into the business and he said
yeah basically is the sound technician I
was like hey man what the [ __ ] are you
talking about you got a cheeseburger hat
on first of all and you're coming up to
me asking if I the comedian by
profession needs a [ __ ] intern and
you want to be a sound technician I mean
I guess maybe he's talking about the
podcast but I don't think it was anyway
he was like he was like yeah if you know
anything you know about venues that need
anything and I was like I got to call
the venue's obviously people are so
[ __ ] weird huh anyway
anyway that guy walked away from me
without a job because I didn't have
anything to give it to him give it to
give give to him I'm gonna go do
personal training today to do it and
we're gonna do bat I'm gonna do my back
you know why cuz I needed to look like a
[ __ ] goddamn mountain I I got an itch
the other day [ __ ] I was itching my
back and I was going with the [ __ ] he's
causing this and I had to look in the
mirror and I looked and there was a
[ __ ] Sherpa setup with a [ __ ] tent
and he was cooking over rocks and flames
and I was like ah god damn it they
started building a [ __ ] campsite on
my back Jesus Christ I go like what the
[ __ ] is I start itching I'm like god
dammit what is that I look there were a
bunch of [ __ ] horses dude galloping
and I look closer I said what the [ __ ]
is that greenery was really beautiful
anyway it sucks that I have that on my
[ __ ] back now cuz it's so goddamn
Rocky
the other day I was [ __ ] was itching
my back and I was like what the [ __ ] I
was going like it was my lower back and
I'm like itching it like was [ __ ]
going on and I had to look I had to
[ __ ] get one of those makeup mirrors
and I put it around back because I
wasn't in the bathroom but I saw this
mirror on the side of the ground I
looked brown bag and I he's dead it's
like I punch a little as I got those
ants I look closer and they were [ __ ]
filming the new Lord of the Rings movie
on my back and I go why are you guys
there I think it goes like this
cuz it looks because we need cuz it
looks like where we film Lord of the
Ring it's like Jesus Christ dude anyway
Oh should we do this other ones alright
alright I don't know about this Russian
[ __ ] things anymore
you guys Roman look guys are terrible at
taking care of their health whether it's
knee injury bad back me or something
more Scott or some worse guys are
usually more comfortable rubbing some
dirt on it you know I'm talking about
than seeing a doctor I'll do it myself
and it's time to stop this and it's sad
well look the same is true for erectile
dysfunction
studies show that 70 percent of guys who
experience edie don't get treated for it
thankfully Roman created an easy way to
get checked out by a doctor and get
treated for IDI online Roman is a one
stop shop where you can do you can chat
with a licensed u.s. physician who can
treat Eady and if safe and appropriate
ship medication right to your door with
Roman there are no waiting rooms awkward
face-to-face conversations that's the
other thing too a lot of guys look I
don't want it to be awkward no
uncomfortable trips to the pharmacy you
can handle everything discreetly online
all I have to do is visit get Roman
dot-com / Congrats complete an online
visit chat with a doctor and if the
doctor decides it would be taste safe to
get to be safe and appropriate then
they'll ship genuine medication right to
your door and discreet unmarked
packaging it's unmarked said don't gotta
be feel shameful for a free online visit
go get go to get Roman comm / Congrats
that's get Roman dot-com / Congrats for
free online visit get Roman comm /
Congrats have you guys seen on Netflix
they just dropped this movie always be
my maybe and it's very cool to see
comedian Ali Wong do this movie because
I love I love her I love her comedy and
she's such a sweetheart and I see her
all the time obviously I work with her a
lot of the comedy store but it's it's
cool that she is doing this movie and
apparently it's going gangbusters people
are watching it it's it's like one of
those movies where did like here's the
deal have you ever had a friend where
you were secretly in love with I know I
have
ever have that one woman that got away
maybe you have but this one's written by
and starring comedian Ali Wong and fresh
off the boats Randall Park who I know I
said Ali is hilarious but Randall Park
is hilarious dude that guy makes me
laugh he's just he's kind of humor might
he's is he's like one of those guys and
this is no knock on his looks but he's
like one of the guys where you just he's
funny already just by looking at him and
I don't mean he's funny looking he's
actually handsome but he just makes me
laugh and he's very funny as delivery's
great it's not your typical romantic
comedy but it's it's it's really cool
it's on Netflix now you can watch it and
it's in select theaters the film is
rated pg-13 and always be my maybe
streaming now on netflix go watch so
yeah I'm chillin dude I'm just gonna be
chilling oh I want to do this I want to
do the most 400 this one really where is
it I don't see it I can't wait to get to
the most [ __ ] up Instagram post of the
week this is such a good one
here we go cash app congratulations is
brought to you by cash app the most
popular app named cash app bro
you got to see this this was a great one
this was sent to me by somebody I don't
know but this is the most [ __ ] up
Instagram post to the we're good this
one's great
I I don't you know sometimes I don't do
this most [ __ ] up Instagram post of
the week because it got kind of like I
did a lot of them and I was like okay
where does it go and whatever and I know
people love this segment and they keep
hitting me I'll get the most [ __ ]
position plus we people send me post up
most [ __ ] up it's gonna possibly but
this one dude I was like I got to do it
okay so this is of a picture of a girl
posing hardcore at dinner she's got one
of those stupid [ __ ] drinks that anyone
would drink because soften its got like
a [ __ ] drink with like a peel and
you know just have the drink don't put
[ __ ] in it that I can't drink so this
girl's doing it she's in a red dress
it's so photoshopped the photo you know
a lot of makeup on this girl but also
photoshopped okay and she's doing it
like this she's doing it like this if
you're on the video podcast she's doing
it like this like almost touching her
hair Connor but not touching her hair
cuz it's sexy when you're kind of almost
doing something but not actually doing
it right like if you look at somebody
from far away you're like is it mouth
open or closed you just get a [ __ ]
bone doggie because of it anyway here it
this this is the actual caption I can
tell how unintelligent a man is by how
stupid he thinks I am first of all hey
first of all the fact that you made this
about men already is just amazingly
genius you don't know it but the
accidental genius okay and also within
the first line the only thing that we
know is you're insecure okay that's it
she writes the person you are looking at
first of all talking about it like it's
not her but it is her hey are you Ricky
Henderson then don't refer to yourself
in the third as the person you're
looking at the person you're looking at
has attended the best educational
institutions in the world been top of
the class all of her life
smashed seven years of law school and
training to become a lawyer no lawyer
has said I smashed Law School unless
also you're a guy and you do date-rape
sailed through three Wall Street firms
to date sailed is exceptionally
intelligent intuitive and has worked
very hard for everything she's rightly
rightfully deservingly achieved earned
her cell
without relying on anyone else all right
and we'll continue to accomplish
greatness for many more years to come I
mean you don't know that
who knows could die you know if you
happen to be mistaken expect this this
drives me nuts dude
Queen to behave like a basic B first of
all just say [ __ ] cuz you're you we
know what it means
second of all when when women refer to
themselves as queen dude it's it's it's
so cringy it's like when a guy says he's
the king like like I'm sorry LeBron is
this [ __ ] but that he goes by King James
is the [ __ ] worst dude there's no
king of basketball it's so [ __ ]
cringy to me like I feel it in my heart
like when when people are like oh that's
a queen look at the way she [ __ ] ran
her own clothing line Queen no Queens
are running a clothing line you know the
Queen's doing sitting around by the way
here's the other thing you don't want to
be a king you don't want to be a king
you're a guy you don't don't call
yourself a king Oh God
like when it guys it we got it we got a
booth in [ __ ] tau Kings only like
dude here's one thing that is for sure
about a king if you're a king you [ __ ]
so bad
think about Kings think about how think
about who actual Kings that rule lands
you [ __ ] so bad you're lazy you're in
your throne or you're in your bed you're
eating grapes you know nowadays you're
watching [ __ ] [ __ ] on net flow
sir Hulu or Amazon Prime and you're just
sitting with your legs when when Kings
lay down dude
their legs are so far apart because it's
so disrespectful a king never lays down
with his [ __ ] knees together he's
always got his legs open and his balls
out like it's a [ __ ] to be eaten that's
a king that some kid yeah and they're
eating off of their belly dude you think
Kings [ __ ] good nope and I guarantee if
you're calling yourself a king in modern
day society here in America or [ __ ]
Ohio or Indiana or whatever the [ __ ] cuz
you got a table at a club you [ __ ]
you're basically saying you [ __ ] bad you
splurt in a matter of seconds and that's
it and your bracket could Cat Cat ain't
even that hard dude I'm no king you know
why
come on down a boner City where we got
boners all day long and I'll have sex
with you for 11 minutes swear to God no
longer because then you're trying to
prove something you're no King dude you
splurt in mere seconds so if you're a
queen I mean just don't call yourself
anything that has to do with the Royal
you know there are some people out there
that call themselves princes - and those
people I like to call Persians because
that's who does that hey I'm the prince
hey what's up on the prince
hey what time we left so hard in me and
my friends were like we came out we came
out we I came up with the most our
meaning the most Armenian thing you
could possibly say this is the most
Armenian thing you could possibly say
okay so if if you if you were in
someone's house okay and and you touched
their face
by mistake right or even on purpose this
is the most Armenian thing you could say
hey dog okay hey dog don't touch my face
I don't like that I don't I don't come
to your house and like put my fingers in
your face and stuff like that I don't
come wow that's the most Armenian [ __ ]
you could possibly say is this someone
touched your [ __ ] face in a house and
you said I don't come to your office and
put my hands in your face and all that
[ __ ] you don't see me coming to your
house and putting my hands in your face
and all that oh my god
you know why cuz they always find some
[ __ ] [ __ ] to be disrespectful about
that's so not disrespectful hey bro did
you ask - did you ask because Armenians
[ __ ] loved to be disrespected even
though they pretend they're like it's
about respect but they love to get
disrespected that's why they're always
being like hey hey hey don't lower the
volume Dawg we're all here don't lower
the volume on on the during the
commercial we're all here what if we
wanted to buy what's on the TV bro
that's not cool bro I mean imagine how
exhausting it is dude with wearing the
glasses with the [ __ ] that are that
are so darn sunglasses that are so dark
up top but then fade lighter as they get
lower sitting like this dude sitting
like this bro oh [ __ ] man so funny they
dude
no no Armenian there's no mood if you
are in Armenian and you like any movie
more than star Scarface you're not an
army
straight up they want everything to be
like scarf they want life to be like
Scarface so much it's unreal like
Persian Armenian life they want it to be
like Scarface so bad and it's so not and
it's and they try so hard and so [ __ ]
funny dude for [ __ ] sake I have a
friend well my best friend's Persian and
he's just like you know Oh bro it is it
is like that it is like Scarface for
Sookie
oh man life is like a first you get the
money then you get power then then only
then comes respect and they work at a
[ __ ] like a kiosk in the mall you
know you're like really like you're like
then you can get after you get respect
then then you can get the the family
plan with a mobile you can get a family
plan if you have that oh [ __ ] dude like
say hello to my little friend Nima he's
the Manager he will help you oh [ __ ]
dude [ __ ] I want to chill with all the
Armenians and just chill one day god
they love oh it's so funny I go to a
cool spilled coffee on my white shirt
karma for making fun of Armenians ah
[ __ ] I used to go to coffee bean by
talking about where I was talking where
I was where there were so many Persians
and [ __ ] and I used to love I wanted to
be I wanted to hang with them so bad but
they didn't look like they would like
man I would do that joke I would do I
did a joke something like what I was
talking about now on stage sometime and
at the haha cafe there were a bunch of
our meetings in the crowd and dude it
was so fun man we were [ __ ] laughing
I was making fun of a lot of saying that
kind of [ __ ] and I was like did you love
the movie Scarface and we were all laugh
and dude [ __ ] that shit's awesome
see that's why it sucks it's like
you could take what I said and be like
oh I was a bashing but I think that [ __ ]
is so wack it's when you're [ __ ]
making fun of someone with someone like
that shit's love dude it's [ __ ] love
man like look we're all in this together
it's [ __ ] awesome if you make a joke
then that's love especially that's what
I do that's what I love in my life is to
make jokes if I'm doing that I love it
anyway this [ __ ] girl thinks she's a
queen who may also be sitting there
looking pretty posing with a cocktail in
her hand wearing a nice dress who
probably thinks doing these things means
doing well at life who will jump at the
first opportunity to offer herself to
any man who shows her the slightest bit
of attention or an or an ex note in
exchange for an ego boost or for himself
at her expense as she clearly has no
self-worth respect or morals values has
accomplished nothing in life and only
her has her looks to offer which will
fade very fast I mean Jesus Christ then
a merely reveals your lack of vision
intellect and failure to distinguish
gold from stone Jesus Christ I mean this
keeps going the sad truth is you are
obviously also an unintelligent basic
being just like the basic be who is the
only type of human you may be able to
seek an invalid validation from your
non-existent confident self worth
describing the need to be associated
with validated by basic B as an
embarrassment is quite an understatement
in my humble opinion I mean nothing is
humble about this opinion you called
yourself good-looking a clean
you said you sailed through [ __ ]
three Wall Street firms and went to the
top-notch school and and you're like
trashing guys and and you and you and
then you end it with in my humble
opinion what is this world and the
comments are slay icon Oh
Hans another one that people throw
around you're not an icon because you
wrote a [ __ ] caption you [ __ ] icon
dude it's just also when you write a
post like that
no bashing involved here like you're
only the only thing that is apparent is
that you're so insecure nobody like have
only people to like you know I'm
intelligent you don't like who you
[ __ ] Kanye West dude nobody [ __ ]
let other people say those things about
you when you say that the only thing I
think is like oh wow everyone always
says this about you cuz stro so weird
putting people back years too sad though
honestly really really sad like it's you
know I don't mean to be punching down
but kind of sad like I'm obviously not
gonna say her name so you don't [ __ ]
trash because I don't want that but my
whole point is these captions they gotta
go you're the first to go they gotta go
these captions just dinner at dinner
here let me short your caption for you
had some drinks that's all that happened
here that's all that happened okay Queen
all that happened is you had dinner
you're acting like you're on top of a
mountain and it took you six weeks to
get up there nothing happened you know
what happened he put on an outfit these
are long captions they gotta go some
comedians do it don't talk
your [ __ ] comedy you know when you're
on my comedy is shaped and evolved and
this and that all really let other
people say that about you you and other
people say it about you I don't want to
hear it and if you're saying that about
yourself other people don't say that
about you by the way
straight up stop romanticizing your own
life if you romanticize your own life
the only person you're bringing down is
you this is a cult dude these are the
things we learn at the log cabin and
I've got a [ __ ] red laser pointer and
I point to all sorts of Instagram posts
I say no no no this is a no and what did
she do here and what did this guy do
here somebody raises her hand yes Linda
he said he was a king correct and what
is he doing he's just sitting in front
of a [ __ ] bottle of Cristal correct
and there you go Linda you deserve some
[ __ ] who wants to be sucking and
[ __ ] Linda and Linda goes ooh I would
like here man somebody goes I'll do it
oh great
this is it the hedonistic lifestyle
congratulation congratulations Linda you
get your [ __ ] in Craig will you please
go here [ __ ] I'll be happy to cool
there's some [ __ ] yoga mats out and
the torque in the tallgrass go do it
outside take it to the limit and then
and then Armenians collect it oh did you
know where that songs from that's from
Scarface it's so funny because alright
I'm gonna name an elder because I talked
about how I liked her [ __ ] movie Ali
Wong and I'm gonna give her a [ __ ]
like so far the elders the comedians
that are elders Bryan Callen Brendan
Schaub
Theo even though I never gave him his
pin and certificate I forgot to [ __ ]
bring it to him and Ali Ali Wong because
we love Ali Wong and she is the new
elder for the log cabin she is invited
when we have our our [ __ ] thing going
on and for always be my may-maybe movie
kicks ass go check it out on Netflix now
now
I'll give you a little hint true babies
know what's up cuz we got a [ __ ] stay
backing up the Brinks straddle iakh okay
so look you guys I'm gonna wrap this up
download the cash app for free on the
App Store or Google Play market and you
can download the Crystal Lea app I
believe watch the first few watch the
first part of the podcast before anyone
else is [ __ ] live buy new merch at
the store Chris Lea calm
we love your support thank you so much
for real it really means a lot
restocks keep coming so keep checking
and you can also get gift cards at the
[ __ ] store if you know another baby
and their birthday's coming up you can
do that
subscribe to the YouTube YouTube channel
all this [ __ ] helps our podcast by the
way rate and review if you're a real
baby your true baby and you really want
to [ __ ] get it to this LA cabin leave
some reviews really helps us out thank
you very much you guys oh and I have
some big news that I'm going to announce
probably on the next podcast some big
big news
that's very cool about a [ __ ] career
endeavor that I'm going to be doing and
I'm very excited very very excited about
it actually so that's what's up thank
you very much you guys are the best you
guys the best watch man on fire and
incorrigible or white my black comic or
comedians of the world thanks you guys
are are the [ __ ]
[Music]